I can't be all the way.
Don't think that applies to a British
Iraqi gay nonbinary and also identifies as
Muslim person.
I think you're out of your line.
I identity or lane Irish,
Italian straight white male
from Chicago who he'd like.
I just think we don't need
all these labels. You Glamor,
you are allowed to be whoever you fucking
want to be and I support the fuck out
of who you are. Always do your shit. Well,
it's almost always people that don't have
a lot of other things going for them.
Yeah. Cause you got to, you have to,
when someone says Stephen
Hawking's identifying as a British,
he identifies a debt guy now when
he was alive. Yeah. Brilliant.
British physicist slash
heterosexual atheist,
a heterosexual identify
who by the way was, um, uh,
rebuttal freak riddled with infidelity.
I've never met a guy, so not capable of,
of cheating and found a way
to cheat on his wife. Well,
apparently it gets still get it up.
Oh,
well apparently even though his body
didn't move, his car could feel things.
That was his sign.
The scientist he used to go to was Eric
Weinstein told me about this. I was like,
what? He's like, yeah, he's a freak. And I
was like, wait, what? And he's like, yeah,
he used to go to strip clubs and there's
like videos of him like rolling into a
strip club in the wheelchair. Like
he would go. That was his thing.
Where'd you hear it littered with
infidelity. Did you hear that?
He cheated on his wife all the time.
We were in that fucking movie. The,
the whole reason that he,
well,
I mean the whole reason that he left his
wife was because he fell in love with
somebody else.
But wasn't it like a nurse who was taking
care of what the truth was that he was
watching my balls.
If you Google,
if you Google Stephen Hawking, he was, he
was always fucking around. Oh. You know,
come on man. He was always
fucking around. Um, yeah.
That's once he got a taste
of the good life. Yeah. Once
he got to taste good. Yeah.
Man. That cosmology cash. Yeah.
You know what also helped me like my
cock and the play by the rules the world
dealt me. The shitty has got please. I'm
a super genius. Please. Gary's. What?
I fucking agree. Do whatever the fuck
you want to do and you want to leave me.
You should leave me. Why would
you only fuck me? Yeah. I'm, I'm,
I'm barely here. I'm a machine
now. I use this finger to talk.
No, it fell apart. It was his eyes and
his fucking and his mouth. That's up.
Why he couldn't use his hands. It
was just his eyes, right? Yeah.
Wasn't it as kind of a
thing where he could kind of
click? He would do. He would,
he would look at something too. He had a
thing where it was take the away, then I,
he would look at Shit and it
was maybe I want to see your,
so can you sit on my face? Face
face. Don't kill me though.
Now I have can't figure out the universe.
I don't smother me with your pussy.
I need to figure out how stars work.
Are black holes real or is
it just a brown star? Please.
I don't want to drown in your pussy.
I'm still on the subject of dark matter.
I'm trying to figure out the universe
before I know in my pants. That's what I,
that's one of the strippers that he
looked up what it was called dark matter.
I try to, I'm trying to think
around dark matter. Dark matter.
I could see her with a big old fur
coat. Hell yeah, a big old for Bush.
I see a big old message with a, with a,
a pencil because her nails are too long.
Logs can't text that dark matter.
Is that possible that you could grow your
fingernails to girls with long nails?
They probably have a terrible time
texting. Well, how did they touch with,
they try to touch with their finger.
Right?
But if you have a crazy ass long nails,
you'd be like [inaudible] voice text. Oh,
I always text the whole time.
But then you gotta use your nose just
to get to the fucking microphone thing.
That's what this, that's what I was
just reading about how this worked.
He had a infrared sensors on his glasses.
See what I'm saying?
I was on his eyeballs
movements in his cheek,
which then translated into a software
program that a lot of them to navigate a
system without his hands
and then eventually turned
into his speak his text to
speech. I just want to fuck
Ken sound one fuck that.
Facts speak functionality
which takes techs,
techs rights and turns it into
speech in his iconic voice. Yeah.
He apparently he liked that
voice and didn't want to
upgrade it. Cause like Siri,
like if you talked to see like who do you,
do you have a specific kind of Siri
like my Siri is an Australian lady.
Like Hey Siri.
I Dunno what's cracking bitch.
I don't know how to respond to that.
Okay,
okay.
Does not a Syria, but
that's how I have, I have a,
okay,
didn't she? Would you like me
to search the web for love? Ooh,
that minus, I think it's the same one is
British. I think we have the same one.
I used to have an Australian lady.
They swapped me out the new, uh,
maybe they don't like Australia.
The new,
upgrade it fuck out his voice in 2004.
He was a good enough with it.
This is how I talk.
I will always be this. I am a bro Man.
It was funny for you heard his voice.
It was like Yo, what's up with Stephen
Hawking? It's real hardcore. Yeah,
like a super ghetto
voice. Yo Yo, what's up?
The talk to Gie up in this pitch
is a pigging out this motherfucker.
Then fuck what's up with
this door drinking Hennessy
and coke trying to find out
what the fuck is happening with
black matter g black matter is his,
that's his alter ego. Black matter. That'd
be, that would be a great stripper name.
Google stripper.
Black matter stripper black got exist.
She does. Or porn star first start
with stripper. Oh that's fine.
That might be a porn star name. Then
stripper named black matter. Yeah.
That will be how to actually,
they used to be.
They used to be a or no dark matter. Dark
matter. Dark matter saw black matter.
Black matters.
Now we're going to get some better.
I can't wait to the Internet lights that
up. Racist piece of shit had a guard.
A skinhead.
It never ends. Redhead, skinheads. Find
A, an exotic dancer named dark matter. No,
it's God.
If there any exotic dancers that
listening right now get on the DL down at
spearmint rhino trying to keep
it on a steak tip. One of them.
Atlanta Strip clubs. Dark black ones.
What was it? What's it called? Uh,
like little Wayne would go and throw
money in the area. What's uh, what's the,
what's the most popular one in Atlanta?
Jamie knows you're there.
The black culture know about black
Twitter. Black Twitter. Jamie. Jamie.
You'll tell us
it's a real famous one,
right? Yeah. Yeah. There's like
fierce ones where people get shot at.
It's like the most famous one. It was
of gunfights there and shit. Magic city.
Magic city. Magic city. That's the most
famous one in Atlanta. That's the big,
that's like the one dark ladies
and gentlemen coming to the stage.
Dark matter here.
A magic city to magic city.
Oh Shit. Shop shop. Let's
see. What did they have Dave?
Look at photos. The photos was
one of the thuggish looking.
The guy had a flat blim brimmed
hat on. Go to photos. Look at that.
Is this where you want to go? Oh
wait, whoa. Damn. Okay. We got to go.
Is that dark matter? Dark matter is
the one, the third, third one with the,
but Jesus go too far. Right? Far
right upper. That's dark manner.
That's our girl. Kapow look, come.
It doesn't wait. What the fuck?
Like pay for photos of the night.
Oh,
what was going on on January 12th look,
get the dude with the fuckable and
on January 12th is that snoop Dogg,
who's the guy with the white
hood? No, some fake snoop
Dogg. We get them thuggish.
These are thuggish looking.
Oh, he's got to look at that.
Whenever you got people that are standing
there with fanning out hundred dollar
bills like and just drinking Fiji
water. Yeah, that's not my place.
Oh
yeah.
I like all these dogs matter to the main
stage. Dark matter. Ladies and gentlemen,
dark matter.